how do I get sin is the Institute of
arson ideas unique festival combining
days full of talks and debates in
philosophy politics arts and science
with evenings full of music and dance
get your tickets for the world's largest
musical philosophy first of all how that
I guess in dog you know there's this
sense that every single story or
narrative that we grow up with about
living forever warns us you know it's it
so there's a warning that I know I think
that's a longest rubbish I don't I don't
have a problem with that at all I think
it's because I'm gonna say something
right now that probably nearly every
single person in the room is going to
boo me for saying I think reproduction
is a form of transhumanism because it's
I want to live forever and because I
can't I'm gonna pop out a crotch fruit
who will live forever for me well so I
think that actually your point about the
manifestations of life is very true that
transhumanism isn't just you know some
ghost in the machine uploaded sentience
all nearly all religion not all but
nearly all religion and I'm guilty of it
because you know we write we are
activists we do things to leave a legacy
we do things to leave sort of
reverberations these are all forms of
wanting to live forever because they're
wanting to be remembered and having
children is just another version of that
and so I think that for me the concept
of transhumanism is any anthropocentric
compulsion to perpetuate human existence
I mean philosophically say see humans go
there's always going to be a species
that's on top it's just as pointless
does it really matter that we eat your
tests on that is transhumanism I
actually agree with that point I think
we have children pretty much out of
egotism and desire to sort of continue
some strange make a claim on the plant
does it matter something else would take
well I'm not I'm not an effortless so I
don't believe that you know all life is
suffering and we should kill every
animal as well as ourselves so I'm I'm
not I'm not Pro asteroid actually unless
it's just a human killing asteroid but
um but yeah I think that what we so just
as you know hetero white dude shouldn't
be taught
looking for women and white people
shouldn't be talking for people of color
we shouldn't be speaking for other
species but we should be making a room
and making way and being ethical and
being ethical is not sustainability it's
stopped murdering them
stop encroaching on the earth which is
not our territory but it is a very multi
vocal territory and in that sense
whatever comes out on top afterwards
fine but we account we should be
accountable and responsible for our
species and we should be doing what we
can to not be a horrible what Michelle
says calls the parasite species we are a
parasite species we take without giving
and we do it within our species and we
do it upon the earth and I'm not sort of
talking about a cataclysm because
Cataclysm like the you know
transhumanists that lives forever but
becomes a crazy hell again that their
alarmist things that really don't attend
to the very ordinariness of the scenario
I think that slow and careful activism
can wind down the species in a very
thoughtful way get your tickets for the
world's largest music and philosophy
festival how the light gets in dog